evening and welcome to tucker carlson
tonight i'm will kane in for tucker
a day after the fbi's raid on former
president donald trump we're starting to
see what a permanent national split
looks like a divorce
nobody wants to say it out loud but it's
true
and this is not simply a break between
democrats and republicans no that's
that's too simple
what we're seeing is divide between
people who are willing to use the power
of the state to silence their opponents
and those who are unwilling
what's held this country together since
the civil war
it's not the federal code it's not even
the bill of rights as important as that
document is
remember the soviet union had a bill of
rights it guaranteed freedom of speech
and equal rights but in practice
the bolsheviks assassinated their
political opponents and sent their
dissidents to the gulags as barrier
boasted show me the man i'll show you
the crime
now what's kept us functioning through
the centuries where the bolsheviks
failed
is that our constitution
separated powers and prevented a
uniparty
we've also had an unwritten
understanding the state power will not
be used shall not be used for improper
political purposes
the law must be enforced equally without
political considerations and once you
lose that common understanding
it's mutually assured destruction
no one has any reason to uphold the
system so the system will collapse
the late antonin scalia made this point
back in october of 2011 speaking before
the senate judiciary committee it's one
of the most important videos you can
watch and here it is the response i will
get and you will get this from almost
any american including the woman that he
was talking to at the supermarket
the answer would be
freedom of speech
freedom of the press
no unreasonable searches and seizures
no quartering of troops in hope those
marvelous provisions of the bill of
rights
but then i tell them if if you think
that a bill of rights
is what sets us apart you're crazy
every banana republic in the world has a
bill of rights just words on paper
what what our framers would have called
a parchment guarantee
and the reason is
that the real constitution of the soviet
union
you think of the word constitution it
doesn't mean a bill it means structure
say a person has a sound constitution
here's a sound structure the real
constitution of the soviet union
which is what our framers debated that
that whole summer in philadelphia in
1787 they didn't talk about the bill of
rights that was an afterthought wasn't
it
that constitution of the soviet union
did not prevent the centralization of
power
in one person
or in one party
and when that happens the game is over
the bill of rights is just what our
framers would call a parchment guarantee
the game is over
a parchment guarantee most americans now
by the way in both parties believe we're
living in a banana republic that was
just described by scalia the trafalgar
group recently found that 79 percent of
americans believe the justice system
protects political insiders two-thirds
of democrats believe that and it's not
hard to see why
the president's son can commit multiple
felonies prostitution corruption and the
federal authorities will just ignore
them in fact
they'll call them russian disinformation
a sitting member of congress can share
bodily fluids and potentially classified
materials presumably not one in the same
with a chinese spy and no one in the fbi
or the media will say a word
millions of migrants can illegally cross
the border and you're not supposed to
notice
but when the president's home is rated
for the first time in american history
those very same cable news propagandist
will celebrate it as a win
for the rule of law
what's in that warrant that authorized
this raid exactly
and why was a low-level magistrate judge
an obama donor who defended jeffrey
epstein's associates the one who
approved the warrant
they don't care about any of this
they're just happy that donald trump was
targeted
attorney general merrick garland has
said in recent weeks more than once that
no one is above the law including anyone
who happened to be president an
ex-president is not above the law there
is no person in this country who's above
the law
in america nobody is above the law no
one is above the law no one is above the
law no one is above the law not even a
president or former president of the
united states
no one is above the law except for
swalwell and clinton and hunter biden
they're mocking you just as barry mocked
his victims we've been building to this
moment for quite some time
for the last four years anyone who
challenged permanent washington has been
targeted by the fbi they've been waking
up to pre-dawn swat team raids with cnn
in tow
they're getting criminally charged and
bankrupted not because they committed
any crimes but because the fbi wanted
them silenced
before the fbi's interview you remember
this story of michael flynn at the white
house in 2017 the fbi's director of
counterintelligence bill priestep he
authored a handwritten note about his
plan to entrap flynn quote what is our
goal pre-stap wrote truth admission or
get him to lie so we can prosecute him
or get him fired
we all know then what happened next
according to a partisan fbi agent named
named peter strzok he's not the most
impartial of sources
flynn told agents he wasn't sure if he
talked about sanctions with a russian
ambassador
that's it now keep in mind talking about
sanctions with a foreign country is
legal and expected when you're the
national security adviser
but for that
the fbi ruined michael flynn he had to
sell his home and where's bill priestat
collecting a government pension
no raid
no jail
the same is true by the way for kevin
kleinsmith do you remember him he's the
fbi lawyer who falsified a fisa warrant
application to secure the wiretap on
flynn
he admitted it he didn't spend any days
in jail not one day in jail he wasn't
even disbarred from being an attorney
and as for jim comey the fbi director at
the time well
he bragged about the fbi
you look at this white house now and
it's hard to imagine two fbi agents
ending up in the sit room how did that
happen
i sent them
um
something we i probably wouldn't have
done or maybe gotten away with in a more
organized investigation a more organized
administration i thought it's early
enough
let's just send a couple guys over
and
so uh
we placed a call to flynn said hey we're
sending a couple guys over
uh hope you'll talk to them he said sure
nobody else was there they interviewed
him in a conference room at the white
house situation room and he lied to them
and that's what he's now plead guilty to
what did he think they were coming over
there for
i don't think he knew
i know we didn't tell him
to them it's comedy
two americans of banana republic
declassified documents of course prove
that the fbi knew the clinton campaign
invented many of the russia collusion
allegations they were the pretext for
the entire probe
james comey went ahead with that comedy
with that banana republic action anyway
that's because what we've had for years
is an fbi that's interested in really
one mission and that is eliminating
rivals of
the uniparty and permanent washington
as with the bolsheviks they use pretext
to get what they want last night's raid
of the former president's home had
nothing to do with the retention of
classified materials you can handle
missing records with a subpoena
you don't come kicking the doors in and
blow opening safes
and that's why the feds never raided the
home of sandy berger who literally
shoved classified documents in his socks
or hillary clinton's home or david
petraeus who shared military intel with
his lover
no raid
the wall street journal by the way is
now reporting the feds claim this raid
had something to do with cocktail
napkins
and notes from kim jong-un
right
everyone knows what this was really
about finding something anything
they can use to keep donald trump from
running for president now here is the
interesting question
why
well he's a threat
to the entrenched unelected power in
washington the biggest threat ever faced
from the beginning donald trump was an
outsider but not just an outsider and
outside the declared war on the
military-industrial complex he stopped
buying their weapons and sending them to
ukraine
so they impeached trump
as axios reported just two weeks ago
donald trump plans to gut the federal
bureaucracy if he's re-elected in 2024
taking a butcher knife to the
administrative state that means
eliminating career government employees
installed by barack obama
and nothing terrifies a career
bureaucrat
more than losing their grip on power
look on the one hand some politicians in
both parties do appear to recognize this
threat florida governor ron desantis for
example is calling this raid a sign that
we're now living in quote a banana
republic
and andrew cuomo a democrat who's no
stranger to the damage of open-ended
investigations
just called the raid a major threat to
the credibility of the fbi
on the other hand the republicans leader
in the senate mitch mcconnell waited 24
hours before he demanded answers from
the fbi tim scott of south carolina says
we need to wait and let the process play
out john cornyn sent out a few retweets
kevin mccarthy calling for reforms
really
how do you reform this
this is the fbi director on august 4th
do you agree that the allegation of
secret collusion between president trump
and russia was a hoax yes or no
i
i don't think that's the terminology i
would use but i think there's been a lot
written on this subject and uh both in
the special counsel's report the
inspector general's report no it's fine
so that's not a term i would use okay
uh do you agree that the hunter biden
laptop was not russia disinformation
uh now you're asking about an ongoing
investigation uh that i expect our folks
to pursue aggressively and i just i
can't comment on that okay and you
possess the laptop right
uh again i can't discuss that nothing
ongoing investigation
you know many people like to point out
that chris ferray was appointed by trump
christopher wray is a member of
permanent washington who doesn't like to
discuss anything including why his
agents concocted a plan to kidnap the
governor of michigan or how many fbi
agents were active on january 6th the
fbi gets away with all this because they
are permanent fixtures in washington as
is
your national media
andy mccabe is always on cnn these days
peter strzok and john brennan and james
clapper regular fixtures on msnbc so is
former fbi counterintelligence official
frank
fogelizzi
watch this revealing moment from last
night figalizzi informs msnbc producers
that the term raid is a little strong so
msnbc changed the chiron in real time to
obey his command
agents by the way don't like the word
raid they don't like it it sounds like
it's some kind of
you know extra judicial non-legal thing
it's the execution of a search warrant
it's a court authorized search warrant
the takeaway here is not that the
media's biased you know that or that the
fbi should prosecute hunter biden for as
in the famous words of stephen a smith
smoking crack
you know that as well
we're not calling on the fbi to raid
eric swalwell even though he's been
sleeping with fang fang the chinese spy
what we're saying is that if the biden
administration doesn't immediately take
steps to dismantle this uniparty to stop
the fbi's corruption to take down
permanent washington to terminate
christopher wray and merrick garland for
starters
then these kind of raids will not end
republicans will eventually take power
and then they'll do the same thing 10
times over they'll raid swalwell and
garland and hunter biden and that'll be
just the beginning
and will that be good for the country
probably not
but it will be inevitable
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight